In the United States of America, an historically
bizarre series of events has been unfolding.
When the sitting president, Donald Trump,
helped to foment public outrage with false
claims of election tampering, it led to a
violent insurrection by right-wing protesters
who descended on the U.S. Capitol, resulting
in destruction, theft, and multiple deaths.
Those events took place on January 6, 2021.
Two days later, Twitter made the decision
to permanently ban Trump from the social media
platform, with @TwitterSafety writing:
"...we have permanently suspended the account
due to the risk of further incitement of violence."
While people online debated the benefits and
drawbacks of that decision, the House of Representatives
immediately set to work on drafting up Articles
of Impeachment.
And on January 13, 2021, Trump became the
only president in United States history to
be impeached twice.
In the midst of all of that, a question arose:
If we can hypothetically remove Trump from
office mere days before he would be leaving
anyway, what else can he be removed from?
The answer, as usual, comes from Twitter,
where someone had the bright idea to propose
removing Trump's brief cameo in Home Alone
2: Lost in New York.
Priorities, right?
"Excuse me, where's the lobby?
Down the hall and to the left."
The idea went one step further than just removing
Trump from the movie.
Instead of just deleting the scene, one Twitter
user made the case for giving young Kevin
an eerie vision of the future, calling for:
"[A] petition to digitally replace Trump in
Home Alone 2 with 40-year-old Macaulay Culkin.
"
Macaulay Culkin, star of the first two Home
Alone films, is very internet savvy.
He's collaborated with multiple people in
recent years to create comedic content -- much
of which pokes fun at his most famous role.
It's safe to say that the former Kevin McCallister
still has a lot of fun with Home Alone hot takes.
Naturally, that means people can't feel truly
assured that Donald Trump should be removed
from Home Alone 2 until the star himself gives
his blessing.
And guess who showed up to do just that?
"Can I help you?"
"It's me.
It's Macaulay."
After much discussion, Culkin weighed in on
the original tweet, responding with one simple
word: "Sold."
But how did that surprise cameo in Home Alone
2 even happen in the first place?
It probably won't come as a surprise to hear
that Donald Trump was more responsible than
anyone else for his brief cameo in Home Alone
2.
In an interview with Insider, Home Alone director
Chris Columbus revealed the entire oddball
story behind Trump's brief moment in the film,
saying:
"Like most locations in New York City, you
just pay a fee and you are allowed to shoot
in that location.
We approached The Plaza Hotel, which Trump
owned at the time, because we wanted to shoot in the lobby.
We couldn't rebuild The Plaza on a soundstage.
Trump said okay."
However, in what also won't come as a surprise
to many, Trump's go-ahead came with a somewhat
self-centered catch.
Columbus went on to say:
"We paid the fee, but he also said, 'The only
way you can use the Plaza is if I'm in the movie.
So we agreed to put him in the movie, and
when we screened it for the first time the
oddest thing happened: people cheered when
Trump showed up on-screen.
So I said to my editor, 'Leave him in the
movie.
It's a moment for the audience.'
But he did bully his way into the movie."
So, what are the chances that Disney actually
would digitally remove Trump and replace him
with an older Macaulay Culkin?
The Home Alone franchise is a Fox property,
which means it's also, now, a Disney property.
And if there's one thing we know about Disney+
, it's that the people behind the platform
don't mind editing old movies to include weird
stuff.
"Maclunkey."
The classic Tom Hanks mermaid comedy Splash,
for example, has a scene where Darryl Hannah's
butt has been digitally hidden by CGI hair,
as she runs towards the ocean.
Suffice to say, there was no such CGI in the
original film.
As for a Macaulay swap in Home Alone 2?
Well, the chances aren't great, but it's certainly
worth noting that Trump's cameo was already
cut from Canadian broadcast network CBC's
airing of Home Alone 2 as far back as 2014,
according to The Guardian.
Who knows?
Maybe next year we'll be watching this Christmas
classic on Disney+ with a few seconds missing.
"Merry Christmas, ya filthy animal."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.